hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen and we are here for another
festive Christmas episode of cooking
stuff I don't even know what's been
going on but peppermint mocha from
Starbucks is one of my favorite drinks
so today we're gonna be making
peppermint mocha shots now we're making
a little candy shot glass as well
we're gonna be using this mold here so
we're gonna be melting down these candy
melts putting them into here and then we
ready making the peppermint mocha drink
to put inside of it but it's not gonna
be a hot performant milk because if you
put a hot drink into a candy Cup it's
gonna melt so that's not gonna work out
well so things we need are these shot
glass makers and these candy melts so
the first thing we're gonna do is I'm
gonna make the shot glasses cuz these
have to set for a pretty long time like
I don't know how long but these are it's
probably gonna take a while I got a new
knife thank you Susie I love knives so
much this one is so nice so I guess this
is gonna be the first use of my day
knife let's cut up holy it's just so
sharp
excuse you I'll leave that mmm I love
Christmas let me tell you what it's
really good
these candy melts are absolutely
delicious so you probably should watch
this but I'm not going to so if you
don't see another video for me this is
why I didn't wash my mold they're gonna
melt this up in the microwave I'm not
really sure how long but you should put
it on half power because you do not want
your candy melts divert start do
yourself give it a little mix this is
probably gonna make one cup oh my gosh
this is so hot I'm burning I'm burning
I'm burning my flash burning my flash so
now we're gonna be just dumping that
into here ooh this isn't hot a lot at
all like one bag is gonna make like
three cups this looks like something
from my nightmares wobbling oh my gosh
do you guys have a favorite Christmas
recipe something that you make with your
friends or your family let me know in
the comments below I would love to hear
about it and try to recreate and mess it
up completely so I'm gonna set this off
to the side and then we're gonna make
our peppermint mocha mixture that's
gonna be going inside
our little peppermint shots I sure hope
this works now that our candy melt shot
glasses whatever you want to call it or
sitting off to the side it's time to
make the peppermint mocha and I am so
hyped for this you guys don't even
understand so for the peppermint mocha
we're gonna need whip cream 1/2 tbsp of
peppermint syrup 3 tablespoons of baking
cocoa 3 tablespoons of warm water or - 6
shots of espresso but we're just gonna
use Starbucks coffee 2 cups of milk and
mint peppermint chips it's time to make
our peppermint mocha keep wanting to
close this but it doesn't close yeah not
really sure what to mix this in mmm
Rhea but today we're gonna be using the
sangria pitcher to make oh wow that was
very scary so you're supposed to do this
fruit in here and then it kind of like
infuses the water but we're not doing
that we're doing something else so we're
gonna put in our cocoa water oh wow I'm
making a mess that looks like when my
dog doesn't feel well and he has an
upset tummy shouldn't I wasn't a blender
what was he thinking
that looks pretty melted in the milk
those well this smells delicious already
yet mixed up so we have to add our syrup
we've got some peppermint syrup do you
say syrup or syrup I'm curious but I'm
gonna say it how I want to say it knife
you weren't this is so sharp I just
actually can't believe it mix it up and
then it's set to add 4 to 6 shots of
espresso
I think we're gonna be more peppermint
because I put a lot of coffee in here 90
calories for two tablespoons it's drugs
am I supposed to put these chips in
there doesn't say these fractions that I
found on Google we're not very I'm very
good I'm not sure what I'm supposed to
do with that I'll figure something out
cuz I'm smart I feel like I should try
it first what if it's not good what if I
have this at my Christmas party that I'm
probably not even gonna have and people
don't like it it's just a little sick it
doesn't really taste good I don't think
there's enough chocolate or enough mint
or enough coffee it kind of tastes
actually really terrible to be honest
with you so I think we're just gonna
carry on with the video and act like
this is delicious let's go check on our
peppermint melted shot glasses oh boy
so it's been approximately I'm not sure
how long but it looks like our shot
glasses have completely molded so I'm
gonna take this out and then we're gonna
fill it up with this really disgusting
peppermint mocha knockoff drink so I'm
gonna put this in the freezer for a
little bit just because maybe that I
don't have room in my freezer this is a
refrigerator for a minute maybe that'll
make it taste less like crap but I'm not
sure okay let's pop these guys out it's
like this mold is birthing a shot glass
gonna pull it out oh oh this is so silly
Wow can you believe it having triplets
just don't let go here you go what's our
last one these look really good so if
you guys do this and expect for these to
mold up really really quickly I can't
lie to you I did this a few days ago so
I made these ahead of time because it'll
probably take you maybe five or six
hours I think to completely mold don't
expect it to be something that's like
real quick because it is not what a
disappointment I feel like making these
baking videos has really set me up for a
very successful life because I fail a
lot and I am so okay with failing
okay let's fill these guys up
look at this here we go feeling mmm no
it's delicious doesn't it I hope that
you try to recreate this and let me know
if you can come up with a better
peppermint mocha recipe because this was
not a very good one
I haven't used whipped cream in a while
I better test it okay looks good
oh no it's going into the yeah look at
this
Oh No shoot okay well I've done some
things some things have happened we have
one good one now we're gonna add our
peppermint flakes onto the top
Wow Martha Stewart come at me Rachael
Ray what's cookin good-lookin well here
they are these are really incredible
peppermint mocha shots I think this is a
really great thing that you can make for
a holiday party or something you should
probably not follow this recipe the only
thing that I did correct was make the
shot glasses they look pretty good feel
like I should try it huh look I'm
disgusted at my own creation
[Music]
it's like an acquired taste
mmm well thank you guys for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this fun little
holiday hmm
whatever you want to call it if you guys
try to recreate this recipe let me know
I would love to see if you guys do it
better than me because I'm pretty sure
that's something that you'll be able to
do quite easily if you guys have any
other recipes that you'd like to see me
do for the holidays leave those in the
comments below and I will see you in the
next one hopefully the next video was a
little more successful than this I'll
see you later bye
[Music]